so i was i was 24
and i was running ads in my space and i
was getting 15 to 20 to 1 returns in a
local market and i've been doing this
for like a year at this point so i was
like i felt pretty good about myself
and then there's this competitor who
moved into my area
and somehow we hopped on the phone and
uh
and he was just killing he was just
killing it he was doing like he was
selling more people than we were i was
like what the [ __ ] is this guy doing
right and he told me that he was
converting how many percent of his leads
is converting and i was converting two
and a half times
more leads than he was like i was he was
converting 10 i was converting 25
of my leads like i was killing it but i
was like what the like how is this even
possible
i mean i was spending 100 a day and he
was spending
500 a day and he would spend
15 000 and he would make 60
and keep 45 and i would spend three
and make you know whatever 25 or
whatever
it was and i you know i was making 22
and he was
he was making twice as much money as me
even though he was spending five times
as much
and that's when i was like wait none of
this [ __ ] matters like it's just about
who makes the most money
and so at some point you're gonna like
just everyone all your [ __ ] will get
less effective i'm just telling like it
will be less excuse me less efficient
in terms of spend but that's part of
scaling
you